High schools across the US are
boosting student access to college by
letting kids rack up college credit
while still in high school.
The Indiana-based 21st Century Charter
School offers a distinctive model.
While 95% of high schoolers who earn
college credit do so via AP or similar
high-school-based programs, 21C is
actually getting kids to campus. This
approach is challenging. 21C had to align
its schedule to local colleges, handle
transportation costs, and find funds for
textbooks and tuition. Plus, there's a
skepticism as to whether high schoolers
can do college work. But there are also
clear benefits: Getting kids on campus
helps bridge a crucial psychological
barrier, especially for first-generation
college goers. Students have earned more
than sixteen hundred college credits and
17 degrees, all at no cost to their
families. It's too early to suggest that
21C's model works, but it's a promising,
practical strategy.
What do you think of
letting high schoolers take classes on
college campuses? Let us know in the
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.